yeah welcome to this 15 minute game
against old named woody shook something
it's not some no no name no explanation
what this name may mean is pretty new to
find familiar - let's check the air - 15
minute this is to one player and 5
minutes ok I played the English defense
trucky defense with b6 let's see what he
was going from the under traditional
main line which is one of the most
aggressive ways to play ya f3 Black has
some more than one option there's a very
aggressive one and f5
I'm I'm going for that the ideas to play
this intending Knight f5 if he captures
aged six I've got to the check and take
on h6 this weekend's the dark squares
really too much ya know I play Knight f5
sacrificing pawns I already have
sacrificed one tall if he takes d7 it
will be two pawns
the compensation is some play on the
dark squares and rapid development right
now I'm immediately threatening Queen h4
this is some something that white needs
to take care of the normal way to do
that is Bishop f4 after that I think
black captures on e6 wow really yeah
this is really something else is smooth
okay I won't think too long here give it
a check first and then see what what's
going on okay I can I can just yeah why
not actually and check and grab the rook
the Queen doesn't have many squares but
we are still with with castles I'm
immediately on f3 also it's it's hard to
believe all this
but it was really a fun amazing the
other night unknown ag-1 the sun is just
hanging okay you know just it's not the
threat for anybody - I have age - yeah
should i cancel or is there something
something else out there should cancel
we need to do that fleet but it's not
easy find a small - to develop 92 for
instance I have hook takes a three mate
Knight to rook a three mate yeah the
Queen s is strapped but how is it going
to to untangle himself
yeah what are my next moves probably
taking on e6 urn and 96 or 97 f6 would
be good to get Knight f6 ideas now this
is maybe a good idea trying to get the
Knight to f6 of course it's very much
depends also on his move the pollution
is obviously very yeah very concrete
yeah yeah here I can I can take on their
phones I felt like - he might play
Knightly - I would have g5 on this if he
moves the bishop and this again will get
three I don't think he's threatening to
trap the Queen I am Knight h3 and rook
h1 maybe this could be a possible Queen
trap
I wonder about 96 here okay let's take
this first
maybe Queenie to him maybe Queenie to
was the good with now winning a temple
huh yeah maybe 96 is a good reply now
he's trying to catch the Queen okay I'm
thinking about 96 know Andi 596 and 94
will all 97f success though it's still a
good technical shot is having Queen d2
narrow page one it's not at all easy to
to prevent
yeah the fun thing is 97 2290 of six
Luka h1 Knight g4 check King f1 and
adult heaven which is completely sick
maybe II five yeah if five he takes with
the pawn I have the Bishop check of
course if I took one not really sharp
technically at the moment pawn takes
Bishop c5 and he needs to move the King
had terrible can have one or something
and then there's no Queen traps and
Bishop takes I can take f3 and and twin
the wind the Queen the question yeah
okay maybe it is not so clear for when
the Queen actually because he's still
threatening this this rook each woman
I'm gonna have 9650 M
the line I'm talking about is Bishop e5
Bishop f3 Queen f3 Roopa 3 check King at
396 rook edge one night X if I check if
de Luke f8 check my default is to
trapping even with Bishop c5 fun
after the leave but in this line after
Bishop c5 check again it's not a check
the Kings on f3 okay I can think about
that if it really is on the board maybe
I have to Bishop on c5 I should consider
on an ottoman knight c6 or something I'm
not really sure about Bishop f3 Queen
takes rook takes King takes an amazing
he even knight c6 is not not working at
the end so I should be fine
what move 96 97 96 is interesting
because there's also the line 96 Bishop
f4 I'd inform which was yeah yeah so
let's check it again Bishop a3 Karenia 3
Ruka 3 check King takes on the lead of
the line Knight to c6 look h1 and added
strapped unbelievable
really no way to really amazing okay
let's see six fish laugh all night
deform 24 push-ups e5 Queen takes e5 p
c5 rook h1 what the heck is this
they are probably asserts it's not
enough like
maybe 9797 f6 with us tonight
g4 idea I cannot spend all day here when
you're losing on time again at the end
about the position ok the ideas of him
they cannot really move Queen d2 or
something that look f3 wins so I have
I'm really expecting Bishop f4 and then
I would go knight f6 threatening Knight
g4 of course is such a tactical in the
same position really it's easy to
imagine that I'm I'm I'm playing
complete nonsense and and we both be
both making a many mistakes him very
very lightly okay Knight f6 isn't
threatening Knight g4 because that's the
bishop on g7 he goes d5 blocking the
bishop I've got Bishop c5 and 94 so as a
serious move now maybe can can even play
Grealish mom's just exchanging the Queen
I didn't see that at all
not that I'm sure that it is good but
didn't didn't really see the the whole
move how to continue maybe I am maybe
Bishop d6 maybe push up to d6 you like
to get rid of this patient
okay let's check briefly m95 cd5 how do
I continue I can take d5 just with the
bishop so difficult to see a direct
continuation down yeah come on I like to
smooth let's play it maybe you can take
a plain idea like 512 for my another
sister that's still not evolve okay yeah
what I'm basically hoping is to
exchanges some active pieces him yeah
this is really funny with the Queen on
h2 GeForce really an amazing move no I'm
not not sure I thought the material
grabbing that I did it's really the best
way I mean I'm pretty sure that this is
just bad g4 but I'm not sure if this was
the way to go
it's simply so technically complicated
that you have a hard time to to get an
idea to how to play in this limited time
okay Ken Leung I think there should be
captures now hard to believe that he
wouldn't take now on f6 or d6 takes on
d6 okay I just okay
hard to believe but he is playing
something else okay okay yeah look h1
yeah let's grab this wow just what the
poem is there really no gauge one take
here I didn't really think about panties
not quite sure why it's not exactly
difficult to see
I don't tell me the queen is strapped
and this would be would be just terrible
really no news I can't believe it yeah
like what I can't believe I said I'm not
even able to to get halfway decent
material for it yeah I didn't think
about politics
yeah I see no mood what what can I do he
just takes and I cannot cannot cannot
get the Queen out
yeah that's not even something silly
like Knight age five or something where
I can sacrifice a piece to to get it out
absolutely no nothing no move resins
sometimes you really ask yourself where
you playing this game you can't win
against this nonsense unbelievable the
g4 is really the only two entities that
can probably force a madman or a
computer okay let's let's look at this
briefly
okay ninety six wins outright with an
attack of course - two came and this is
probably you know maybe yeah I played
this too quickly usually I would invest
a bit of time but if you're you're burnt
with all this time losses and you try to
play more quickly okay but I cannot
believe this at all
nevertheless I cannot believe that what
should be better here
he takes e5 is the best move now 96
about equal and of course he's playing
all the the best moves now we should
before
night take CD uptake seems to be good
hmm yeah then this is this is crap
probably Bishop g5 CD v g5 no it's good
okay didn't see that one yeah I simply I
forgot about G porn takes is just I
forgot that you can take with the porn
simply other moves are of course good
having something like this this wins
after this I can I can get the Queen out
but funny enough the computer even
assesses this is better for white yeah
well of course it's it's much easier to
to invest like two minutes see at 596
that's not even the difficulties I mean
it's pretty clear that I've got all
pieces out I only need to castle and
he's played king e to move the pawn
three times never developed a piece f3
g4 I mean this is so unspeaking ly bad
but of course you can you can probably
win in the attack on a g3 probably good
but complicated
how does he how does he usually ate
terrible terrible compass on -4 already
this is probably optimistic if you let
it run a bit longer something like this
here
look at he age threatening King King
away and just winning the attack the
Alice's disaster this position you might
say rook the ADA this is difficult no no
it's not really you're just attacking
with all pieces you don't really need to
calculate it I just thought that okay
don't spend too much time this is crap
anyway and win this no and this is
indeed it is slightly tricky it is
slightly tricky the Queen does very
square yeah thanks for watching